throughout history we've learned that
all predictions come true
here are ten of the worst predictions of
all time
in 2005 the co-founder of YouTube Steve
Chen said the following there's just not
that many videos I want to watch he was
expressing his concerns about YouTube's
future when he started it in 2005 a year
later he sold it to Google for 1.65
billion dollars in 2006 David Pope from
the New York Times said the following
everyone's always asking me when Apple
will come out with a cell phone my
answer is probably never the iPhone came
out a year later in 2007 in 1995 the
founder of 3com Robert Metcalf said the
following I predict the internet will
soon go spectacularly supernova and in
1996 catastrophic ly collapse Robert
said he would eat his words if he was
wrong at a conference in 1997 he put his
article in a food processor and aided in
1981 the pioneer of wireless
communication Marty Cooper said the
following cellular phones will
absolutely not replace local wire
systems in 1943 the president of IBM
Thomas Watson said the following about
computers I think there's a world market
for maybe five computers in 1946 Darryl
sonic from 20th Century Fox said the
following television won't be able to
hold on to any marketed captures after
the first six months people will soon
get tired of staring at a plywood box
every night in 1929 the inventor of the
cinematograph Luis Jean Lumiere said the
following talking films are a very
interesting invention but I do not
believe they will remain long in
fashions in 1903 the president of
Michigan Savings Bank advised Henry
Ford's lawyer Horace Rackham not to
invest in the Ford Motor Company because
the following reason
the horse is here to stay but the
automobile is only a novelty a fast the
great Thomas Edison said the following
in 1889 fooling around with alternative
current also known as the AC is just a
waste of time nobody will use it ever in
1876 william priests from the british
post office said the following the
americans have need of the telephone but
we do not we have plenty of messenger
boys just because an expert makes a
prediction doesn't necessarily mean
they're right all the time